fantastic job oh thank you I was really
nervous I wasn't sure what to expect
tell you it was awesome and really
important message politics and there's
you know you're telling this story that
you have in a couple of days you've
written a book of burden so you wrote a
I I want a duck I mean order an essay
for the New York Times about it so I
outed myself as an undocumented in the
New York Times rite 2011 that's 11 and
then I made a film so incredible yeah
and so that you you wrote you directed
you produce this film I just kind of
wanted to make a statement about you
know there's 11 million undocumented
will in this country right people call
illegal and one of them made a film you
know like I wanted to kind of make that
artistic statement it was the article
you wrote this sort of a jumping off
point for this film it was a jumping off
point not for the film but really more
for define American um we run a campaign
called define American calm and it's all
about kind of elevating how we talk
about immigration in this country right
that it's not a Latino issue might as an
American right and a citizenship in this
country I think citizenship in this
country is more than pieces of papers
right no I'm an American I just don't
have like to the papers to show you well
how would you define American yes a
person so I define American you get that
question a lot i define American as
somebody who cost this country their
home this is my home but I also define
American as a fight you know I think
this country since its founding we've
been fighting for what this America is
gonna be exactly right and guess what
like we are too we're fighting for that
and sometimes I think undocumented
people in this country actually show
Americans what it's like to be a man
hate to like fight for it like I have to
work you know to earn people's have to
earn citizenship you know what what are
Americans doing every day to earn their
succession that's a question we should
ask everybody not just people with me
right maybe everybody should start out
not citizens and everybody should earn I
don't know man we have to kick everybody
off the island and I'm not sure we want
that how are you inviting people to get
involved well I mean every civil rights
movement in this country I mean let's
look at LGBT rights movement right where
would that movement be without straight
people getting involved
right I call it like the whirling grace
effect right for every will there's a
grace so at define America and we're
asking people to come out about the fact
that their advocates for us that their
allies right if we're not engaging why
people in black people in this country
then what are we doing immigration again
is an American issue and everybody plays
a role and so do you right I'm anime
book unquote white whatever the hell
that I mean whatever nice try to hide it
I don't know what that means right look
white is not a country where is the
immigration debate right now I feel like
a lot of people think that oh yeah it's
an important issue when she's totally
talked about it but nobody really
follows it to the extent that none of
you might be well because over small I'm
directly connected by it right I don't
think I don't have a driver's license I
don't have a passport I can't see my mom
these are tangible things right and to
be undocumented means to be obsessed
with papers like I've spent pretty much
my whole life obsessing about papers um
so for us this issue has been so overly
politicized it's overly politicized that
the goal is how do we change the culture
in which we talk about it and if you
think about the LGBT rights movement the
culture changing for the politics
challenge the pull cheer on the issue
change before the politics chance right
with immigration that hasn't happened
yet also we're trying to get the
politicians need the backing of the
culture of Phil yes to create the space
so it is up to us to you know have this
conversation before the laws can and
have a more honest conversation about
your film is called documenting yeah and
people can find out where it's playing
back yeah documented the film com we are
we open in San Diego today May
twenty-third we're opening in Washington
DC in seattle next friday and then
denver chicago then CNN is gonna air the
film in the summer great so yeah apps
documented the film calm go check it out
jose antonio vargas thinking she's 14
stomach you for the time thank you